buenos días pues si todavía queda mucho
por saber se acerca de esa salida de la
costa de minas que fue su portavoz quien
indicó esta salida sin dar más
precisiones simplemente dijo que en la
jornada de hoy lunes en algún momento
subiría a la página internet de la
embajada de francia en ese país un vídeo
que dejó el embajador algunos medios
bien los rusos indican que sería porque
el embajador no presentó sus cartas
acreditaciones no ante ante el
presidente de lukachenko sin embargo en
la página de embajadas no puede ver que
eso sí se se hizo se presentó esas
cartas que lo acreditan como embajador
de francia en ese país y esto data de
diciembre de 2020 pero sin necesidad
hilar muy fino lo otro es que svetlana
tica nos calla quien es una de las
máximas opositoras al régimen de
lukashenko justamente está terminando
hoy lunes su visita de tres días a parís
ella fue recibida por la inflexión quien
es el encargado de asuntos exteriores
del país de hecho lo deje aunque por
ahora no ha hecho ningún comentario
sobre la salida
su embajador y hay que recordar pues que
pica nos calla pues ella viene haciendo
toda una campaña en europa visitando
varios países de la unión europea que de
hecho puede ser muchos de estos países
no reconocieron los resultados de las
elecciones de hace un año precisamente
cuando lukachenko pues se atribuye la
victoria para ser reelegido un sexto
mandato mientras que ética nos calla
indica que ella habría ganado esas
elecciones y esto viene también a
sumarse a varios
digamos roces diplomáticos que ha tenido
belarús uno de ellos en agosto cuando
ella pues echó para atrás cuando ya
había dado su visto bueno a la nueva
embajadora de eeuu en ese país una
embajadora que pues que eeuu no tenía
desde 2008 en aena minsk y también en
marzo había expulsado a todo el personal
de la embajada de letonia después de que
las autoridades de ese país durante un
campeonato de hockey hubieran demostrado
la bandera de la oposición
y por último pues hoy se están reuniendo
en bruselas los ministros de asuntos
exteriores y justamente a su llegada el
ministro de letonia pidió que se
impongan aún más sanciones económicas a
ese país